il a fait une interview et c'est vrai
qu'il y a une journaliste c'est pas
c'est dans le bus elle s'appelle Sarah
le coeuvre elle veut toujours parler de
moi alors où elle est amoureuse de moi
ou elle a un problème la fille qu'elle
le dit c'est la fille de Fabien ah oui
c'est vrai je peux pas pécho tout le
monde j'ai déjà pécho ton père euh
ok c'est bon calme-toi un peu comme ça
je peux plus la blairer elle parle tout
le temps de moi elle est insupportable
et donc elle a chauffé Dave sur moi il
est allé quand même ah oui il a dit que
je le rendais antisémite d'accord
excuse-moi c'est quand même pas grave
franchement alors on va regarder mais je
vous jure que c'est grave elle est
malade
l'interview est dingue l'interview
dingue c'est très limite je pense la
vérité que Dave il a il a du Bouddha
dans la tête il est tombé sur la tête il
y a quelques temps
il était sur Europe 1 et il savait que
je l'aime pas trop il me l'a dit en
direct à la radio et ça me fait monter
en estime ah oui je trouve ça bien il
paraît que tu m'aimes pas il a dit et je
trouve ça courageux
[Rires]
la réussite qu'il fait et j'aime pas
trop comme il parle aux gens je parle
pas de ce même d'ailleurs c'est
chroniqueuse mais
il parle aux gens comme si nous prend
pour des enfants ça m'embête un peu
ouais il me rend un peu antisémite et
comme mon père était Juifs c'est
peut-être oui
il me rend un peu anticipé
il a 75 oui bien sûr il est compliqué
il faut l'attaquer parce que c'est très
grave de dire ça l'antisémitisme
c'est pour c'est pour la règle générale
que ce genre de phrase n'est pas audible
c'est même si toi tu dis ok il a 75 ans
d'accord mais faut pas laisser entendre
aux gens qui nous regardent que c'est
que c'est possible de dire ça c'est pas
possible moi on m'a envoyé l'article
avec la phrase il a commencé
une blague de très mauvais goût avec moi
aussi je crois que c'est Théo qui me l'a
envoyé cet après-midi je me suis dit
c'est une blague de très mauvais goût
c'est nul mais comment c'est
inimaginable de dire ça vous imaginez un
mec qui parle d'un d'un présentateur
musulman qui dit Morand islamophobe ça
n'existe pas c'est extrêmement grave
parce qu'il a dit ils auraient dû le
reprendre et publier même si voir ce
genre de reprendre les bien sûr ils
dorment
avec Sarah ils sont gentils mais là et
Sarah c'est à la caisse
de pas réagir c'est impossible le plus
grand moi je trouve que c'est pas de
réagir c'est donc pas réagir parce que
lui Dave les mecs il a quel âge
maintenant 75 ans
de faire des trucs
c'est un prénom qui existe pas trop mais
franchement c'est un peu voilà ils
auraient dû le couper au montage ils
veulent faire du buzz avec ça très bien
mais il y a des limites quand même c'est
pas en direct
ils ont laissé comme ça et
prends-la en fait c'est repris nulle
part personne n'en parle ailleurs on
s'en fout en fait non non c'est rien il
y a pas d'alerte tout le monde s'en va
c'est normal en fait si on avait dit ça
pour autre chose c'est vrai ce que tu
viens direct on avait dit ça pour une
autre cause c'était le bordel c'était
fini
ce qui me gêne plus c'est moins Dave que
les réactions des autres c'est-à-dire
personne ne dit rien ça personne n'a
repris il y a pas de signalement il y a
pas de trucs il y a pas d'amande ça sur
une antenne il y a pas de problème mais
ça c'est 100 fois plus grave que ce
qu'il a pu se passer sur ce plateau ça
c'est vraiment grave le fait qu'il y a
une embrouille un débat une insulte moi
ça me choque pas ça c'est dégueulasse et
c'est même pas la violence du propos
c'est réduire quelqu'un sa religion
c'est parler d'antisémitisme alors qu'il
veut juste dire qu'il vous aime pas trop
mais quel rapport en fait c'est c'est
scandaleux pas parce que c'est vous en
fait donc on va faire du buzz donc on va
faire du buzz on va mettre
j'ai déjà été interviewé par les deux et
j'ai pas eu l'impression qu'ils avaient
un problème avec Cyril non non j'aime
beaucoup Nicolas volé
deux trucs qui cliquent voilà c'est tout
c'est pas qu'ils ont fait j'ai envie
qu'on le revoit pour ceux qui nous
rejoignent parce que c'est vrai que même
moi c'est halluciner
quelque chose à la canne à un moment il
était sur Europe 1 et il savait que je
l'aime pas trop il me l'a dit en direct
à la radio et ça me fait monter en
estime ah oui je trouve ça bien il
paraît que tu m'aimes pas il a dit et je
trouve ça courageux
ah Cyril Hanouna d'accord ok oui parce
que
et je l'ai connu avant qu'il fait la
réussite qu'il fait et j'aime pas trop
qu'on me parle aux gens je parle pas de
ce même d'ailleurs c'est chroniqueuse
mais
il parle aux gens comme si nous prend
pour des enfants ça m'embête un peu
ouais il me rend un peu antisémite et
comme mon père était juif c'est
peut-être pas oui
et il était venu faire sa promo et il
croyait que j'allais pas lui en parler
donc parce qu'il m'avait déjà découpé
dans une interview donc tu es qui c'est
assis je dis pareil que tu m'aimes pas
alors quand il est arrivé devant moi
mais non non moi je t'adore tu étais là
Valérie
non non il était effectivement arrivé il
était même surpris que vous lui en
parliez on va faire comme si de rien
n'était et en fait mais il a il avait
apprécié votre franchise en disant le
fait que juste
le pire finalement qui a eu après
dédouaner vous dédouanez les deux les
deux animaux vous les dédouaner vous
dites c'est pas eux machin mais à partir
du moment où tu veux pas en direct c'est
nous quand on sort
tout le monde parle en même temps et
c'est pas ça c'est que si c'était en
direct nous on sort des saucisses ici en
direct on dit on est franc on peut dire
des conneries derrière on est puni et
que la chaîne paye des amendes mais là
là c'est pas en direct où sont les
associations où sont les associations
pourquoi les associations à mon poste
créneau je vous mette un coup de pied là
si c'est Dieudonné qui dit ça qu'est-ce
qui se passe il a raison il peut sauver
il peut partir enfilature ils vont te
chercher si c'est Dieudonné qui dit la
même chose moi Nouna me rend antisémite
qu'est-ce qui se passe
pour pour ça parce que c'est pas la télé
ça c'est le web donc on va faire une
sorte quand même c'est pareil c'est
quand même un média
dans l'histoire de TPMP et même d'autres
émissions j'ai jamais entendu un truc
aussi gratuit en vrai mais imaginez si
ça ça sort sur son plateau c'est une
dinguerie c'est c'est là parce que c'est
sur Internet on dirait etc mais c'est
quand même une personnalité connue mais
en plus le pire c'est qu'ils l'ont
repris bah voilà le mec entier
c'est comme ça qu'on l'a vu c'est qu'ils
ont
reprises complètement
tu te fous de la gueule du monde
ils auraient dû ils auraient dû au moins
au lieu de dire def sans filtre Dave
d'érable grave banalise la phrase c'est
scandaleux le média qui reprend ça qui
met ce titre il a une responsabilité
aussi il faut dire au moins que c'est un
dérapage extrêmement grave analyser
cette phrase et vous allez rien faire
je dis rien à l'antenne et puis je tape
derrière vous verrez il y a une enquête
d'ailleurs sur moi je vous le dis qui en
préparation voilà sur mes coups de
pression
je vous le dis sur mes coups de pression
aux autres animateurs aux autres gens
tout ça parce que c'est vrai que moi
voilà quand j'ai un problème je dis rien
à l'antenne et puis j'essaie de
retrouver le gars et de parler face à
face et puis si ça se passe mal ça se
passe mal si ça se passe bien ça se
passe bien mais bon voilà et je me suis
jamais caché ici donc ils font une
enquête actuellement sur mes coups de
pression et sur mes menaces voilà donc
comme je l'ai fait ici les chéris pas
besoin de faire une enquête je vous le
dis voilà donc il y a les gens écris
même un mec giron Anthony je sais que
ils lui ont écrit ils ont dit ouais il
paraît que c'est une note à menacé tout
ça je suis un jour il y a eu un truc et
puis Jérôme c'est un super pote j'adore
en plus je l'adore
donc voilà donc voilà je suis plus avoir
quelques frictions et un jour un
animateur aussi qui m'a écrit je vous le
dis un animateur très connu qui m'a
écrit un long mot et qui m'a dit dommage
que on se soit pas vu je dis bah tu
habites où je vais venir tout de suite
en bas
et je suis vraiment allé en bas de chez
lui et donc c'est en bas de chez lui il
a jamais voulu descendre je suis resté
une journée en bas de chez lui il est
jamais descendu donc voilà lui aussi il
a dit que je l'avais menacé que je
l'avais cherché vous connaissez aussi
Casa voilà je l'avais appelé aussi voilà
donc il y a plein de trucs comme ça donc
il faut une enquête en fait sur tous les
gens que que j'ai pu à qui j'ai pu me
déco de pression mais je le dis si donc
j'ai rien à cacher voilà bah il fait pas
l'appeler je vais pas me demander
de rien on passe à autre chose on l'a
dit que c'était dramatique on peut
rappeler qu'il a 70 ans les gars c'est
pas mon rouler on peut rappeler que
homophobie racisme
islamophobie
voilà de trucs voilà on va pas on va pas
s'embrouiller avec des jeunes les
journalistes et je vais pas l'attaquer
les journalistes à limite je leur dis
voilà faites attention faites votre
métier en plus je les aime bien les deux
et là ils ont été ils ont laissé passer
après voilà ils ont ils ont mis je pense
qu'ils se sont chié dessus aussi ils
sont dit qu'est-ce qu'on fait on va
faire le titre voilà
mais c'est ça il faut mettre serrer la
Nouna après exactement tu crains plus
rien tu peux faire ce que tu veux dire
ce que tu veux tu peux tu peux raconter
n'importe quelle banane mais tu mets
Cyril Hanouna après c'est bon ça passe
d'accord
de bouffon c'est d'une gravité extrême
million d'euros et dire je suis
antisémite parce que c'est ça qui dit en
fait il me rentre donc je suis
antisémite de dire ça au calme et que ça
va le zéro euro de sanction mais faut
arrêter il faut